DO NOT LET THEM DO THIS TO
AMERICA.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS FORMER NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY GIULIANI.
IS THIS ANYTHING MORE THAN A
POLITICAL HIT JOB AND A WARNING
SHOT TO OTHERS WHO DARE QUESTION
THE LEFTIST AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW
IN NEW YORK CITY?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY ARE RUINING
THE CITY COMPLETELY.
IT IS A TRAGEDY.
I THINK EVERYONE IN THE CITY
KNOWS IT’S.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS FOR
LETITIA JAMES TO INVESTIGATE.
FOR EXAMPLE, HIS CAMP CAN’T
ACCOUNT FOR $9 MILLION IN AN
ORGANIZATION I STARTED AND
BLOOMBERG CONTINUED PRAYED HE
NAMED IT THRIVE NEW YORK, WHICH
REALLY SEEMS TO BE THRIVE,
SOMEBODY WE DON’T KNOW WHO.
NOBODY IS INVESTIGATING THAT.
THAT IS $900 MILLION.
THE CITY COUNCIL WENT CRAZY WHEN
THEY FOUND OUT ABOUT THAT RIGHT
NOW BUT NOBODY WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
THAT COULD EASILY BE
INVESTIGATED.
THE NRA, THAT IS RIDICULOUS WHAT
SHE’S DOING GREAT SEEKING
CAPITAL PUNISHMENT FOR WHATEVER
SHE CLAIMS ARE THE ERRORS.
>> JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW HOW SHE
IS JUSTIFYING HER LAWSUIT SO
PEOPLE GET WHAT HER SO-CALLED
LOGIC IS, THIS IS WHAT,  SHE
SAID.
>> MY CALL MICHAEL IS IT FOR
DISSOLVE DISSOLVE AND TO TRY TO
KEEP THIS ORGANIZATION INTACT
BREAD.
>> BECAUSE THE CORRUPTION WAS SO
BROAD.
THEY HAVE BASICALLY DESTROYED
ALL OF THE ASSETS OF THE
CORPORATION.
IT WAS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
ONE OF THE CAUSES OF ACTION, ONE
OF THE REMEDIES WE ARE SEEKING
AS A DISSOLUTION OF THE NRA.
>> ISN’T THIS A LAWSUIT TO CRUSH
AN INFLUENTIAL LIBERAL
ORGANIZATION IN A YEAR.
>> SHE IS A POOR EXCUSE FOR A
LAWYER ANYWAY AND SHE RAN ON A
SINGLE ISSUE WHICH WAS GET TRUMP
.
RATHER INAPPROPRIATE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO WANT TO GET
ONE PERSON.
NOW THIS CASE AGAINST THE NRA
THE NRA BROUGHT SUIT AGAINST HER
.
MY MONEY IS ON THE NRA.
THE REALITY IS THAT THIS IS JUST
A SILLY LAWSUIT.
SHE’S GOT REAL SHAMBLES, THE ONE
I MENTIONED, 900 MILLION, THAT
WENT TO OBAMA’S WIFE AND A
CHARITY SHE WAS RUNNING.
NOBODY HAS THE GUTS TO LOOK AT
THAT.
NOT THE DEA HAS TURNED OUT TO BE
ANOTHER POLITICAL HACK.
>> WHAT DOES THIS ALL MEAN TO
THE CITY?
IT IS KIND OF FUNNY TO SEE CUOMO
BEGGING PEOPLE TO COME BACK TO
THE CITY.
>> IT MEANS THEY CAN’T GOVERN.
>> WHAT HAPPENS TO NEW YORK?
>> IT MEANS WHAT THE GOVERNORS
AT ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO, HE AND I,
DID EVERYTHING WE COULD TO TURN
THIS PLACE AROUND AND DID.
HE SAID THE CITY IS GOING TO BE
FINISHED IF HE KEEPS GOING THIS
DIRECTION.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE REVIVAL
BOWL.
YOU CAN’T DRIVE AWAY THIS MUCH
CAPITAL SO QUICKLY.
YOU CAN’T HAVE CRIME RATES GO UP
.
I MEAN I BROUGHT MURDER DOWN THE
FIRST YEAR 20 PERCENT.
HE BROUGHT IT UP 24 PERCENT.
HOW DO YOU KEEP UP WITH THAT?
>> IT IS SO DEPRESSING FOR ALL
OF US.
FOR ALL OF US WHO HAVE EITHER
LIVED IN NEW YORK OR WORK IN NEW
YORK, IT IS A HEARTBREAK.
AND TONIGHT, OUR MESSAGE TO
AMERICA IS THIS CAN HAPPEN TO
WHERE YOU LIVE IF YOU MAKE THE
WRONG DECISIONS POLITICALLY.
THIS IS NOT JUST GOING TO BE
CONFINED IN NEW YORK.
IF THE BIDEN GANG GETS IN CHARGE
, THIS KIND OF RETRIBUTION
CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO BE SWEEPING
THE COUNTRY.
AND I MEAN THE MIDWEST TOO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE WILL BE CRIMINALIZATION OF
POLITICS IN THE WORST WAY AND
THERE WILL BE DETERIORATION LIKE
YOU SEE IN NEW YORK, CHICAGO,
BALTIMORE.
THAT IS OUR FUTURE IF WE ELECT
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> RUDY, THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NEW YORK WHEN YOU WERE MAYOR AND
ALL OF US WERE STILL YOUNG IN
THE CITY AND NOW, IT IS JUST I
MEAN I SAY IT, I’M ANGRY ABOUT
IT, BUT I’M HEARTBROKEN AS WELL.